[Music]
their pain is clear to see this is
balasore Hospital
and some of the struggling survivors of
the worst train crash this century
some have described this hospital as
like a war zone and it is an
overwhelming feeling being here room
after room full of the injured some on
Floors others in corridors many with
serious injuries and harrowing stories
24 year old Guru kalai Bears the scars
of a huge impact
my legs hurt I can't walk it's broken
and hurts a lot it's broken my arms are
cut my body is hurt head is hurt
he remembers a sudden jolt as he felt
his train smash into another
we were standing near the doors the two
carriages crushed us we were four of us
and I felt throttled as I was thrown out
of the courage and got out I got hurt on
my head arms and legs it hurts
many volunteers rushed here to help in
whatever way they could it is an
unprecedented tragedy for an area that
is both remote and poor
definitely is a challenging time now but
uh our odisha government has happened a
lot of doctor here and nearest is the
doctor Medical Hospital there's lots of
doctors students as working there and
overnight they are working
even for a country with a long history
of crashes the death toll is
exceptionally High
train safety standards in India are
under the microscope again though the
government has made improvements human
error and outdated signaling are still
major issues
as others investigate these people try
to fight through as hundreds of families
mourn and travel huge distances to
collect their loved ones bodies Audelia
Lynch Sky News balasore India